[Musik]
hallo und herzlich willkommen zu einem
neuen blog wir sind gerade in berlin
geladen auf einen die einen kreativen
von kaufland und da werde ich noch
einige von euch treffen und star wars zu
tun als in kooperation
sie betraten
und wir haben die kassen kommen
mit einem feuchten doch eigentlich total
aufgeregt
und ja für die die nicht dabei sein
können habe ich gedacht hätten soft lock
so lange her zu behaupten und wir müssen
jetzt erstmal alle angekommen waren und
wir vergessen immer unsere zahlen wissen
mitnehmen immer
sagen wir's teamcheck schicksal jetzt
gibt abzuhelfen er berliner hauptbahnhof
putzen kennen einkaufscenter
die klappe oder sonst jemand wir können
wir ja quasi auch schon shoppen hier
nur grosse wirkung des riesig
regnerischer tag in berlin wir werden
jetzt aber erstmal einchecken und dann
geht es weiter
[Musik]
so das ist das zimmer beust das geräumig
ist ja riesig
naja eigentlich sind wir nur heute noch
zum schlafen da und morgen früh geht es
auch schon wieder bekommen macht heute
kam ja an das video online
da habe ich mich im zug kaputtgelacht
überauchen kommentare der durch das auf
jeden fall jetzt hier nochmal in die
infobox verlegen falls ihr das man nicht
gesehen und dann schaute ich auf jeden
fall haben sie hat gebaute nicht besetzt
war also ich muss sagen die zugfahrt
gegen durch eure kommentare so schnell
herum gesagt ja wir haben geantwortet
haben sondern ich uns immer abgewechselt
hat bock gemacht
jetzt mache ich nicht einmal ganz kurz
frisch ich habe meine lockenstab schon
lange vorgehalten und jetzt werden
einmal die wellen aufgefrischt
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich mich frisch gemacht habe
jung gezogen wurde hat man o ring
getragen und leute nicht so doof ich
habe nur einen ohrring dabei der zweite
ist einfach nicht dabei also ich hab
dich halt einfach zu hause vergessen
jetzt habe ich entweder die möglichkeit
keine zu tragen
da ich trag die hier davon habe ich zwei
dabei aber ich bin mir unsicher da haben
sie es noch keine hilfe hansa oder nicht
männer
wisst ihr was ich frag jetzt einfach auf
instagram ihr habt immer eine lösung für
mich fifty fifty
ihr macht es mir echt nicht leicht ich
warte ich noch ein paar minuten bis sie
übungen was das irgendwas über wie
privat schreibt mir gerade eine
zuschauerin trag doch nur einen ohrring
das andere ist in den haaren bedeckt
buche
naja ich glaube ich lasse es weil die
mehrheit immer wieder von eintippt ich
glaube auch dass es so viel ist ich lass
mal die habe ich in meiner klatsch
gefunden hatte ich wohl von der letzten
hochzeit zwar noch da drin da sind seit
die ohrringe geworden sein taxi gerufen
und es zeigt sich mal der hammer aus
also ich finde den hut richtig cool ich
finds richtig cool ich würde ihn
mitnehmen eigen gemacht
[Musik]
selbst schwer geld das man leben
bei welchen nicht
[Musik]
okay hier werden so fans die videos
gemacht kann man sich hier was sagen sie
wenn man mag und dann sind da eine hand
vor kameras aufnehmen das endergebnis
zeigt einen stern
ja
[Musik]
auch kohl ausgerechnet
ja ich habe jetzt wirklich gucken was
auch immer das ist nach spaß aus genau
wir haben uns gesagt dass sie das spaß
aus dass müssen uns jetzt muss man
einfach mal ausprobieren kann soweit gar
nichts wissen
das ist nur snacks bewusst
bewegen das ganze
du sollst dir banken weiter weg gehen
noch ein bisschen
du hast es kaputt gemacht wieder
jetzt kannst du auf zehn jahre später
das muss man sich ja noch meine zeit
noch mal raus ja ich mache zwei sache
raus die hat aufgegeben nur zur info
bild nation das brauche ich nicht nach
oben schweben und sich dabei in der
mitte auf cd oder macht sie machen
[Musik]
klicke ich mache heute rezepte besser
man hat es die mädchen gerne herzliche
ganz meter zum gesungenen kaufland
veranstaltung wirklich
[Musik]
[Applaus]
schwarzmann sonstige thema
die verkäufe sind schwer getan
im namen dann aber wirklich sind
die kriegt jetzt gibt an dem nackig
machen
in der gegend sind es rund
[Musik]
auch der spd
wir sind eine der arbeiten wir so gut
wie weg
das sollte wird zurück im hotelzimmer
ist mittlerweile ein uhr stelle ich mal
ganz kurz ab also abschließend kann ich
sagen ist ein schöner abend was ihr
jetzt nicht so gesehen habt waren die
gewinner also ich durfte ja zehn mal
zwei eintrittskarten für das event
verlosen und habe da eben einen kleinen
teil bei der community kennenlernen
dürfen und dessen alles so liebe und
herzliche menschen gewesen und wir haben
einfach einen schönen abend hab ich habe
mich mit denen unterhalten können und
falls ihr das jetzt seht ich danke euch
dass ihr gekommen seid noch mal ich weiß
es sehr zu schätzen
einige kamen aus berlin anderen nicht
einmal haben weiten weg auf sich
genommen
daher fiel vielen dank fürs kommen und
ich finde es immer wieder schön wenn ich
eben leute aus der community mal
persönlich kennenlernen mit gesicht und
das zeigt mir dann noch immer wie
kunterbunt wir sind und wie krass
einfach youtube und backen kochen
verbindet würde ich noch die gute beck
auspacken denn diese goodie bag es ist
nicht nur irgendeine gute weg sondern
drinnen steckt ganz viel liebe von mir
das zeige ich euch jetzt so wir schauen
mal rein ich weiß hier noch von einer
sache und für eine sache die von mir ist
und alles andere lasse ich mich jetzt
mal selber überraschen dass das
sammelalbum mega das gibt es jetzt auch
in den kaufland filialen frühjahr ich
weiß nicht ob er das auch gemacht haben
als kinder hatten wir immer zusammen alt
meine sticker alben und dann haben wir
immer gegenseitig getauscht
echt ne coole zeit also zu sein ist
schon cool also richtig hochwertig
verarbeitet das ganze war mega richtig
cool
okay das ist wie ihr habt ja im block
gesehen dass ich diese spiele auf dem
handy oder auf dem großen screen vor ort
spielen konnte das könnt ihr auch mit
der cam master ab ich kann euch das hier
und in der infobox gerne verlinken für
alle star wars fans ein muss also
die gerne kostenlos herunter facetime
app store und hier ist die vr wurde das
duo auch richtig cool so mein idol
schokolade exklusiv perfekt um den abend
ausklingen zu lassen
ich habe auch noch kathrin direkt erst
mal aufmachen können tauschen
mehr ich tausche ich das in meiner vita
fit und c3po direct essen glitzer karte
also jetzt kommt etwas von mir
persönlich und zwar das wissen wir gar
nicht weil ich wollte es einfach nichts
vor land habe ich die letzten tage damit
verbracht mues jährige zuzubereiten
einzutüten und als für die giveaways
vorzubereiten und zwar sind das die
meisterin die macht energy riegel hier
das rezept noch mit drin das findet ihr
auch als video also wenn die gerne mal
müsliriegel also energiepass zu hause
selber machen müssen für arbeit schule
uni et cetera dann verlinke ich euch das
absetzen gerne in den verbockt habe für
die aktion im markt heute morgen in
berlin der ganzen aktion im kaufland
markt und für das event am giveaways
vorbereitet die energy war so
vorbereitet und ist in 1.250 stück 1250
stück so sieht das ganze aus also hier
habe so ein papier beutelchen mit einem
sticker drauf ist kann sich ja mal
zweiter
meist tritt die macht energy riegel made
by piece jeder und selbstgemachten regel
bekommt das brauche ich jetzt heute
genau das habe ich jetzt gebraucht mit
cranberries mit leinsamen haferflocken
ohne ich kokosöl also richtig lecker und
einfach für power zwischendurch klar und
das hat auch jeder bekommt das war jetzt
die goody bag problem werden dort
geschlafen gute nacht
guten morgen sagt schminke ich mich erst
mal ziemlich echt wieder auf dem ich
nämlich gestern das licht ausgeschaltet
hat kam haben sie auf die glorreiche
idee dass wir doch noch lieber eine
folge black des gucken sollen
[Musik]
so haben sie kämpft gerade noch mit dem
koffer dass ihr zugeht geschafft das war
ein kampf nun koffer zu zu kriegen dabei
haben wir doch gar nicht so viele
klamotten mitgenommen oder sie ist noch
ein bisschen größer
wir gehen sollte machen wir jetzt den
check auto dann geht es super
schaut mal wie ich getroffen habe
[Applaus]
tatsächlich ist das thema längst
kommunizieren auf jedenfalls war ein
super abend vier promis zwei auf jeder
seite hin und dunkel und ich habe mein
bestes gegeben also geringsten
ja ich denke oder eher weniger als 30
glaubt keiner hat weniger als angegeben
wurde
ich war richtig fies das erste mal
aktive musste ich natürlich auch
durchsetzen da irgendwann sicherlich die
jury weltmeisterin werden die iaa hat
das hoffe ich doch mal gut an coole
abend ja da alle zusammen ganz ganz
lieber den habe ich auch im zuge der
kaufmann zusammenarbeit kennen gelernt
und richtig richtig liebt ja und wir
haben jetzt ein taxi
wir wollen nicht scheute
wir müssen jetzt geht's zum bahnhof hast
du hast noch nicht ja und ist schon da
so weiß und hell aus gerade diese
eigentlich vorher schon waren
[Musik]
ja findet einen weg
stimme weg
[Musik]
nebenbei trainieren
sieht ja gar nicht angestrengt auf
wieder daheim mir riesen kaffee gemacht
und halo nicht fragen den kran noch
willst du einfach nein
der schmeckt köstlich als meiner ist ja
wir sind wieder zu hause
wir haben ungefähr 16 ruhig glaubt heute
machen wir großartig nichts mehr hoffen
natürlich dass euch der block gefallen
hat also wenn man schon mal unterwegs
ist auch so ein tolles event
da habe ich mir gedacht nehme ich euch
doch gleich machen werden mein highlight
war einerseits ist 3d foto ich jetzt mal
an dass das zdf mit kulows tanzeinlage
fand ich cool die kochshow es einfach
ein schöner abend und dann sich auch
einige zuschauer getroffen habe die da
eben die karten gewonnen haben das war
auch mein persönliches highlight dass
ich euch meine erkennen durfte und ja
ich habe doch nur spaß ganz cool
ja ja ja ja mal getroffen
die waren echt also die sind genauso
groß wie dieses genau so crazy neben
videos aber ich dem klavier und was soll
man noch sagen ansonsten das habe ich
auch instagram angekündigt ich habe vor
im dezember niederlanden jede woche noch
einen blog hochzuladen also dann bin ich
wahrscheinlich nicht unterwegs sondern
eher hin bochum aber es ist ja auch cool
dann gibt auch immer was zu gewinnen aus
unserem shop im dorf unserem auge und
auch instagram wird auch verlosungen
geben also der dezember ist voller
überraschungen
ich hoffe dass sich der blog gefallen
hat ansonsten die merchandise artikel
von star wars findet ihr in jedem
kaufland also abzukaufen
möge die macht mit euch sein ihr lieben
und wir sehen uns dann im nächsten blog
oder im nächsten rezept video teams